Good afternoon. Welcome to this session,
Education Session 36, entitled "Innovations in
Translating Social and Structural Determinants of Health Across
Population, Community, and Basic Cancer Research".
We're really excited to have you join us this afternoon, and we're going to talk
about social and structural determinants.
So we know these measures are important because they shape
cancer risk and outcomes at many levels, from
population-wide systems and policies to
community environments and ultimately biological processes.
In this session, we'll move from large to small, beginning with
conceptual frameworks and definitions, then
highlighting innovative population-based measurement,
and concluding with examples of how social and structural
contexts can be translated into community-engaged and
basic cancer research.
Together, these three talks offer practical,
interdisciplinary perspectives on advancing socially
informed and equitable cancer research.
So we'll have three talks. The first one will be
by me, and it's titled "Motivating Social and Structural Drivers in
Cancer Research: Frameworks, Concepts, and Why."
Then we'll hear from Jesse Placek.
His talk is titled "Social and Built Environmental Measures: Novel
Spatiotemporal Approaches in Population Science".
And then we'll hear from Shannon Lynch discussing "Social and Structural
Drivers of Health at the Intersection of Community and Basic Science
Research". And at the end, we'll open
the floor for discussion,
and I'll just start with some intros.
So my name is Adena Yanos. I'm an associate professor of
epidemiology at the Mailman School of Public Health.
I'm also cancer population science program
co-leader at Herbert Irving Comprehensive Cancer Center, and I'm
a geneticist and molecular and cancer epidemiologist, and my work
focuses on understanding structural, social, and biological
drivers of cancer inequities.
And Dr. Jesse Placek, he's faculty at the Ohio State
University in the College of Medicine in the Division of Cancer Prevention and
Control, and he's co-leader of the cancer control program within the
OSU Comprehensive Cancer Center.
He has led two NIH projects that both investigate the role of
social and built environment on cancer
disparities. One focuses on breast cancer survival and
whether epigenomic mechanisms might be involved
in associations between social and built
environment factors and cancer outcomes.
And the second project investigates relationships between time-varying
built environment factors and colon and rectum cancer outcomes.
Together, these projects are designed to improve our understanding of
modifiable neighborhood factors and cancer outcomes.
Dr. Shannon Lynch is faculty in the Cancer Prevention and Control
program and assistant director
of the
Office of Community Outreach and Engagement at Fox Chase Cancer Center in
Philadelphia. She's also the co-director of the Center for Biostatistics and
Epidemiology at the Lewis Katz School of Medicine at Temple
University. She received her PhD in epidemiology from the
University of Pennsylvania and her MPH in environmental health
from the George Washington University.
Her work utilizes geospatial and machine learning approaches to
identify and study multilevel risk factors, including biological,
behavioral, social, and environmental influences that
contribute to cancer risk and disparities across the cancer
continuum. Her goal is to translate insights from multilevel
data into actionable clinical and community programs that improve
outcomes for populations disproportionately impacted by
cancer.
So thanks for joining us, and I will go
to the first
talk. All right.
Okay, there we go.
Okay. So my role in this
opening talk is to set up the conceptual foundation
for the session. So I'm going to discuss why this work is
important,
how we define the key constructs, and how these exposures
can be measured. I'll also cover how they can be linked to
biological processes and cancer outcomes.
This framework will set the stage for the talks that follow, especially
those that focus specifically on the built
environment and related applications.
This is my disclosure information.
And I want to begin with a simple premise,
and that is cancer disparities are not random variation.
The patterns we observe in incidence, stage at
diagnosis, treatment, survivorship, and mortality
are shaped by unequal structural and social conditions.
If we focus only on the individual levels and
only on individual level risk factors,
we risk missing the upstream drivers that
shape exposure, that shape vulnerability, and also
shape opportunity in the first place.
So what's exciting about this moment in cancer research is that
translational science gives us an opportunity to connect
all these upstream factors.
If we look at this figureIncluding the
social conditions and policies, institutional context,
these fundamental drivers and how they
ultimately drive or lead to the
intermediate contributors, including social and physical
contexts and lived experience, and
then how they
further go downstream and impact biological
response and genetic and epigenetic pathways.
So all of these biological consequences that are driven
by the fundamental drivers.
So these upstream drivers, macro-level determinants, they
create downstream cancer consequences.
And by integrating these upstream measures, it allows us
a unique opportunity to measure their impact on biological and
population level
processes.
So
the objectives of this
session really is first to
position structural and social drivers of health as essential,
not as peripheral to our work in population science and cancer
disparities research. Secondly, we want to define
structural and social drivers of health and the built environment.
And third, we'll discuss examples of where exposure
data come from across population and community levels and
connect these external exposures to biomarkers, intermediate
mechanisms, and to cancer outcomes.
And lastly, we'll finally make the case that this work
advances disparities research by helping us
understand how downward causation
might inform discovery and intervention.
So one useful framework is the ecosocial
theory and many other theories that are similar.
The central idea is that
our bodies biologically incorporate the physical and social world
across the life course. So embodiment, it really just
considers the fact that our human bodies biologically
incorporate all of the external
stressors that we encounter. So biology is not
separate from
the social
constructs. It's not separate from the physical and social
world. It's not separate from policies, institutions,
neighborhoods, and lived environments.
So all of these can shape, for example, stress
physiology, inflammation, immune processes, and other
downstream pathways.
This framework also reminds us that these pathways operate
across multiple levels. So looking at this
one example, which comes from the ACHIEVE study that's led by
myself and Dr. Jennifer Shui, we're actually looking at
the relationship of macro-level, meso-level, and micro-level
factors on guideline-concordant cervical cancer
treatment, and how all of these multi-level
relationships drive outcomes in cervical cancer and
disparities in these outcomes.
So this framework and similar ecosocial
frameworks remind us that the pathways operate across multiple levels,
from the macro-level systems and institutions to
neighborhoods and communities, all the way down to households and
individuals, and also cellular processes.
And importantly, this ecosocial thinking
asks us to take accountability into consideration.
So who benefits, who's harmed, and through what
systems? So the key message is that social structure is not
outside biology.
It helps produce biology.
I want to define three key terms that you'll hear throughout this
session because the rest of the session really depends on all of these.
So structural drivers are the rules, policies, institutions, and resource
distributions that pattern opportunity and risk across
groups and places. And some examples include
racial residential segregation, lending bias,
zoning, transportation,
neighborhood investment, and carceral systems.
And these are just examples. There are many others.
In the green box, we have social drivers.
So these are the lived social and economic conditions through
which structural arrangements are experienced by individuals, so
by the people and by communities. Some of the
examples of social drivers include poverty, social cohesion,
discrimination, food insecurity, healthcare access.
In this orange box, we have built environment.
So the built environment represents the human-created physical
surroundings that shape everyday exposures, behaviors,
stress, and access to health-promoting resources.
So some examples of built environment include housing quality,
walkability, green space, heat, traffic, pollution,
and healthy retail environments.
So the practical distinction across these three
buckets, if you will, are that structural drivers pattern society
and places. Social drivers and built environments are among the
mechanisms through which these structures may become
biologically relevant. So even looking at this sort of
in this vertical pathway, you can still see the interconnectedness
and how the structure drives the
social, the built, and further downstream, the cellular
and molecular
mechanisms.So
this slide broadens the framework by emphasizing that
structural and social drivers of health
are factors outside the body that shape conditions in which people live,
work, learn, play, pray, where they do most
activities.
The key point here is that they're not isolated, they're
interconnected domains. So just looking at the
center image,
we can see economic stability, neighborhood and built environment, health and
healthcare, social and community context, and education.
And if we go further upstream, so thinking about the
fundamental drivers, the discriminatory
processes or discriminatory policies
that drive the measures in this circle can
ultimately also drive cancer outcomes.
So next I'll present some examples.
And here are a few examples of how we
operationalize economic stability with a focus
on education. Or well, economic stability and
then education. So the major sources for most of these
measures are from the US Census.
So poverty, one example is the percent within a
neighborhood or within a census tract that lives below the
federal poverty line, and this could be in quartiles,
it can be in the overall community, also broken down by race and
ethnicity. The Yost Index incorporates multiple measures.
Income can be measured as household income, it could be income by poverty,
income by age,
the total income amount. And employment is basically
percentages of workers in protective services. That's one example.
And then as far as education, which we can also
gather from US Census,
it can be the percent in the neighborhood with a graduate degree or professional
degree, or even the percent with a high school diploma.
In terms of access measures, and again, these are just examples
that I'm showing from many. There are thousands of examples of measures that could
be used depending on what construct you're interested
in measuring. So at the area level,
access measures might include transportation access,
including vehicle ownership or reliance on public
transportation. It can also include, at the individual
level,
insurance status or other indicators of healthcare access.
And these measures are important because access and access to
healthcare shapes whether people can obtain cancer screening,
early diagnosis, treatment, follow-up, et cetera.
Thinking of the social context
and how we can measure this,
we can measure this in many different ways. So here are three examples.
Social support, including the proportion of
individuals living alone in a community.
Racial and ethnic identity,
so the proportion of each racial and ethnic
group, the proportion of immigrants in a neighborhood, and also
index of concentrations at the extremes.
So this measure considers,
well basically it captures how privilege and deprivation are
spatially organized. And now
I'll shift to some of the built environment basics.
So the built environment, as I mentioned earlier, it refers to the
human-created spaces and infrastructure that people interact with
on a regular basis. And so here examples include
active transportation environments.
So,
here we're not seeing a lot of traffic, but in some neighborhoods
there's heavy traffic, and that can impact many
different health outcomes.
Here is a map that shows a variety
of food
retailers. So thinking about the food environment and whether
neighborhoods have access to healthy produce,
if a neighborhood has a huge
proportion or large availability of fast
foods or liquor stores or things like that.
Another measure is physical disorder.
And this
includes things like abandoned buildings and
graffiti and litter. So there are lots of different ways that
we can quantify and measure the built environment.
And Dr. Placek will touch on this in his talk.
And this slide is showing a few examples of measures.
Again, these are measures that are available through census.
Examples of the
housing environment includes housing occupancy, housing age,
urban rural indicator codes. There are also landscape
metrics, so Normalized Difference
Vegetation Index, NDVI. The percent
imperviousness, so the percent of land made of roads, roofs,
paved surfaces. Aggregation index, and this
is based on the percentage of open versus developed lands, and
aggregation index focusing on high intensity developed lands.
So looking at highly developed lands, so more roads, more buildings, and
less green space.
Other measures of the built environment include environmental
quality indices.
So the overall EQI, it's a domain
that's created by retaining the first component of PCA,
which combined multiple specificvariables.
There's also measures of air quality, water, and land
quality, and you can see there are 87 variables for air, 80
variables representing overall water quality, 26 variables that
represent contamination from pesticides, facilities,
radon, and others.
So where do all these data come from?
If you want to incorporate these measures in your research, you have to be able
to access the data, find the data, and link it to your data sets.
So at the population and policy level,
we see a lot of these measures are
available through census and also the American Community Survey.
Deprivation indices, zoning,
homeowners, loan corporation data for redlining
information and mortgage lending bias,
transportation data, environmental monitoring.
So there are publicly available data sources that can be
accessed
to include population and policy data.
For community and place,
geospatial GIS buffers, land use, food retail,
heat, air pollution, crime, greenness, walkability.
There are also sources for these measures.
In terms of the healthcare context, we think about facility access
based on where people live, screening resources, referral
patterns, payer mix, and quality
metrics at facilities and
health systems. And then thinking about clinical and
biospecimen resources, we can use electronic health
records, registries, including cancer registries like SEER
registries, survey data, blood tissue, pathology,
and multi-omics. So when we think about incorporating
these different
levels of data, we're including geocoded data.
We have to temporally align the data,
harmonize the data with some of these clinical and
biospecimen data, and that really allows us
or provides us an analyzable data structure or data
architecture.
And that's really the goal and
one of the key components in doing this work well.
So,
focusing on the publicly available place-based or
neighborhood-level data available for each domain.
This is another example. You can get data from the USDA,
from the census, from your state registry.
I'm using this example for Pennsylvania because Dr.
Lynch will discuss some data from Pennsylvania.
But you can see a variety of sources for these publicly
available data. And I just mention that there are thousands of structural and
social determinants of health and built environment measures that you can choose
from, depending on your research question.
So this is really going through the
practical data linkage flow and thinking of how we go
from addresses to biological measures.
So first, we think about defining our exposure window.
Obviously, the exposure must occur before your outcome.
So we can think about whether we're interested in the prenatal
period, whether our exposure of interest is really a cumulative
measure, like over the full life course, or if we're interested in
exposures at the screening or diagnosis phase,
at treatment, during survivorship.
So there's a range of time points, and this is something that
you have to consider depending on what your research question is.
Next, we think about geocoding and
contextualizing these data. So a lot
of research that focuses on
addresses and census tracts, we have to consider, do we
have access to residential history?
Because again, if we're thinking about the exposure that someone
may have had
much further back in time from, say, their diagnosis,
we need to be able to consider if they've moved and lived
in very different environments.
Think about neighborhood buffers, mobility, the census tract, and
some of the
redistricting, if you will, like
remapping block group, rurality,
urbanicity, and some of these characteristics of cities
and suburbs, they change over time.
Then we think about assigning the place-based metrics.
So again, built environment
or deprivation, policy, pollution, service accessibility.
And ultimately, we can link these to biologic endpoints.
Examples here are inflammation markers, immune profiles, allostatic
load, chronic stress, epigenetic age, and other
epigenomic
features, tumor features, et cetera.
And then the pathways. So linking all of these data
together, the goal is to model the pathways.
Are we able to investigate direct effects,
mediation? Is it effect modification?
Are exposures more important at very specific critical
periods, or is it important to consider the cumulative
burden of the exposure?
And so this is where population science really becomes
translational, because we take these contextual
exposures, they become variables that can be paired with biological
assays, with pathology, and ultimately with longitudinal cancer
outcomes.So
I just wanted to highlight some
potential
design and analytic choices that will strengthen
your ability to make inferences, especially if you're interested in
making causal inferences between specific
environmental or structural
exposures. So time matters. And so in the
last slide, I talked about the fact that if
we're interested in cumulative exposures, some of these measures may
not necessarily be appropriate. If we're thinking about very
specific critical windows,
then the address that you might have at diagnosis may not
be the most appropriate. So thinking about time
and how it relates to your measure of interest, your exposure
measure, and the outcome is important. Another point is scale.
So scale matters. Are we interested in the parcel, the
street, the census tract, an entire neighborhood or
community, the city, the county, the state, or the
region?
And lastly, mechanism matters. So if we're interested in
understanding whether an exposure is a mediator versus a confounder,
we really have to think about how we're designing the analyses
and how we are operationalizing the exposures.
Then there are some common interpretation pitfalls.
So measurement matters. So some direct measures
are available, remote sensing, administrative data,
perceptions-based data. They each capture different constructs.
So again, it's important to consider what is your research question and
what types of inference are you able to make.
And equity matters. So
I think one key thing in this work, thinking about
structural and social drivers of health, we have to avoid
conceptualizing race as biology.
And we should think about shifting the focus to the fundamental
drivers, such as racism. So outside of systems
of
racism and oppression, a lot of the measures like race
really don't matter as much. But as we think about
the fact that where people live spatially, these things are
driven a lot of times by policies and
upstream determinants.
Deprivation, exclusion, and
place-based, policy-based processes really
drive inequities. And so we have to consider
those in the operationalization of the
measures and the exposures of interest.
And translation matters. So if we identify
modifiable upstream targets,
these are likely to have much more impact on broader
populations.
Yes, we can target downstream individual behaviors
or individual factors, but they're going to have an
impact on one person or maybe a family.
So we should be thinking about how to translate this to
enhance the outcomes and the impact on larger groups,
like whole populations.
And so how might these approaches advance cancer disparities research?
Well,
I would say it can move the field upstream.
So it takes us from descriptive studies,
where we're looking at comparisons between groups, whether it's by race
or by income or by neighborhood, but we're moving from these
descriptive studies to actually
testing the structural and social pathways that generate
disparities.
Secondly, it connects population and basic science research.
So it creates shared questions and shared variables across
epidemiology, community research, mechanistic
biology, so basic science research as well.
And it can improve interventions and community connections.
So it can point us towards multilevel interventions.
So I keep talking about these structural measures, and
if we were able to actually intervene at
the higher policy, upstream,
fundamental level, and again, not just on individual
level behaviors or characteristics, then we really can
improve our interventions and have
a much more impactful outcome
in populations. And lastly, it makes downward
causation in cancer testable. So it enables us
to ask questions about how structural factors or
structural forces become measurable biologic
changes that impact cancer outcomes.
So I will end on this quote.
"The body is a reflection of the land on which we live." And I think
this beautifully captures the core idea that place,
policy, and the conditions
that we live in are not separate from biology.
They are a part of the story of biology, and they are a part of the
story of cancer biology and cancer health equity.
And thank you.
So now I would like to call Dr. Plaisance
up to the podium.
There we go.
Dr. Hanos.
That was an excellent introduction into the concepts, the theory,
the frameworks, and an amazing overview of the
measures that we are typically
encountering and studying in lots of our
population science cancer prevention control studies. So that was excellent.
SoAs you can see from my talk, I'm going to be
talking social and built environment factors, but I'll give you a kind of
heads
up. It's really going to be mainly built environment measures.
At the very end, I talk a little bit about social environmental measures.
At the end, the Yost Index that Dr. Yanos already introduced.
But mostly built environment for the purpose of doing a deep dive into one measure
and seeing how we're measuring this in a way that is
novel across both space and time. I have no
disclosures for myself or family members.
So my whole goal for this session is
five things I'm trying to achieve, and I hope
you can actually walk away with something tangible from this talk.
One, define built environment. Check. Dr. Yanos already did that.
So we're going to actually be doing a kind of repeat of
that. So we should all be able to do that walking out of here.
Two, classify aspects of the built environment,
and Dr. Yanos actually already introduced that as well.
Identify at least one built environment data source.
I think you've done actually most of this, I think, actually.
Four, describe basic concepts, this should be new, of
spatiotemporal kriging. And lastly, interpret
spatiotemporal exposure estimation results.
And these are, as you can see, kind of classified according to Bloom's
Taxonomy, and you'll see this throughout the presentation too, Bloom's Taxonomy.
So this looks familiar, right? So this is everything.
We should all be able to do this. This has already been defined.
Essentially built environment, I'm going to use this interchangeably with
neighborhood throughout the talk, are the human-created spaces and infrastructure
with which we regularly interact. And so the examples Dr.
Yanos has already gone through, I'm not going to belabor the point here.
I'm going to be focusing, as this red box indicates, on built environment physical
disorder or neighborhood disinvestment.
I've been using these interchangeably in the literature,
and others have as well.
Why? So why focus on neighborhood disinvestment or built environment
physical disorder? And I would argue that this is one of the
few measures through which we have very strong evidence, by
few social built environment measures, that we have strong evidence for a
role
in health behaviors and outcomes, various health behaviors and outcomes.
So this paper that you're seeing here is from a 2019 meta-analysis and systematic
review by O'Brien and colleagues that looked at dozens of studies
and tried to organize the literature around the
most common pathways through which physical disorder may be
associated,
that's a giveaway,
with various health outcomes. They came across three pathways, one of
them being stress.
That evidence is kind of backed up in one of the few RCTs that
have been conducted looking at social or built environment factors and
outcomes among humans, and that is
the vacant lot remediation trials in Dr.
Lynch's backyard in Philadelphia,
where vacant lots were randomly chosen for remediation or
not, and individuals were enrolled who lived around these vacant lots
and were followed forward in time.
And those that received the remediation had these outcomes that you
see on the
screen, including lower distress.
Not the best measures of health outcomes or behaviors, but
still, evidence, again, that was supported by this meta-analysis that stress may be
an important mechanism.
And I would argue that disinvestment is regularly
intervened upon all the time. Here's an example.
So a lot of cities have these programs.
Here's one from, this is from Newark, New Jersey, where some of this research
that I'm going to present has taken place, called the Love Your Block program.
Essentially, in short, it's a program that is designed
to go into different neighborhoods that experience high disinvestment
and improve them, just like the vacant lot remediation trial.
Garbage pickup, small repairs to buildings,
residential buildings repair,
and other forms of remediation.
So how is this measured? How is disinvestment measured?
Well, historically, this is not a measure that's new.
It's been around for a while. Robert Sampson was one of the first to measure this
systematically in Chicago in the 1990s.
And back then, there was no Google Street View.
You're seeing Google Street View,
giving away how we measure it. But back then, they measured it by going down the
street in cars. Right? And they would actually do a windshield tour, they would
call it, or windshield audit, where they would audit various characteristics of the
neighborhood. And since they were going down the street in cars and videotaping, it
made sense that they would videotape everything they saw. Right?
This is before we had Google Street View, where we can bop in, bop out, go wherever
we want to go. And so block faces were essentially
lines that we would have measures of disinvestment.
Now, what I want to show you that's still kind of important with that early
research is that what you're looking at with these two streetscapes is
the peg person is going from the one end of the segment to the other,
and the other end of the segment is this other image here.
You can see if you compare the two insets.
And what you see essentially is a nearly identical block face with respect
to neighborhood conditions, whether that's garbage, we see garbage over here,
and we see some garbage over here, too. The buildings look very similar.
And so what that says is that we have spatial autocorrelation.
There's redundant information across a block face.
So knowing something about one intersection tells us something about the other
intersection.
Just keep that in mind. That's kind of a basic definition of spatial
autocorrelation. So what we're using to measure this is no longer
SUVs with cameras. We're using Google Street View because that data is available to
us, and Google Street View is widespread across much of the world now,
including many places where we live.
And so we're using Google Street View to do 360-degree audits
around areas that we pre-select that we would like audits
to be conducted using a program called Canvas that was built by Andrew
Rundle,
Mike Bader, Steve Mooney was involved in that as well, and I was fortunate enough
to begin working with those individuals.
Essentially what it does is it combines a structured questionnaire, just like what
you see on the screen here, with Google Street View.
And we've all used Google Street View, and I'm sure you're
aware of what that looks like. So we trained auditors via standardized
protocol to audit systematically is
kind ofobjectively as possible.
And we audited various measures related to physical disorder.
We also measured for sidewalk walkability, but I'm not going to talk about that
today.
So measures of disinvestment that we looked at were presence of garbage for the
streetscape in Newark, New Jersey, we would say, yes, garbage was present.
For yard conditions, that was a four-level ordinal scale ranging from poor
to very well kept. We would say poor, given the overgrowth.
For building conditions, we would say fair, given the missing fascia board, and
you can also see some peeling paint in the background.
For abandoned buildings, we would say yes, it was abandoned buildings or
buildings with boarded-up windows.
For graffiti, there was none. We would say no. For dumpsters, there were none.
We would say no.
We replicated this 23,000 times using Google Street View,
and at those locations that you see there.
These were the locations that there was a breast cancer case cohort
that was enrolled from these areas, which is why we pre-selected these areas.
These are also the urban areas of New Jersey, if anyone is
interested or knows much about New Jersey.
So we first did some kind of basic measures to look at how fast our auditing method
was, because we did a drop and spin, not go along the block face.
And with that, we saved some time. Ours was the fastest
or one of the fastest available. We also looked at the items that we audited and
how well our team agrees to get a sense of measurement error, which is important.
If we can't measure it well, we can't say that there's something actually there
objective, right? If it's just like randomly people are saying, "Yeah, there's
garbage here." "No, there's not." And so essentially take home here from our Kappa
coefficients are that we can measure these quite well.
Next, what we did is we checked internal consistency, reliability.
Do these things hang together? Where we see garbage, do we see abandoned
buildings? Do we see poor yard conditions? Do we see poor building conditions?
So on and so forth. And what this correlation matrix shows you is that essentially
we do. And then the Cronbach's alpha tells us that we are justified to build a
single score of disinvestment or disorder at each of these 23,000 locations that
you saw.
And so with that, you may say, "Cool, we're done." So we have this measure
of disinvestment across the whole area where cancer case cohort or
anyone else that we want to link these measures to lives. So we're good, right?
Well, no, because we audited in such a way that's
not at an actual person's address, right?
Because if it was at an exact address, we're putting their information into Google
to do an audit, and that's probably not good for IRB or ethics.
So we do it across a random sample. It's actually a uniform distribution
spatially. And then from there, we can
do different
analytic techniques, that's where the kriging comes in, to estimate what the
measures of disinvestment are. Based on the known locations, we can
estimate where individuals are living and what their level of disinvestment is
there. And so kriging relies on something called the
semivariogram, which is depicted here.
Essentially what it is on the Y-axis is, think of it as
standard deviation of the measure you're trying to look at.
For us, it's disinvestment. Disinvestment is a continuous value
after we create a single score. And so essentially the Y-axis
is a standard deviation measure, and across the X-axis
is distance, because we think that it spatially autocorrelates.
This tells us the degree to which it does spatially autocorrelate.
And essentially, I'm going to skip through some of this for the sake of time.
What we can peel off of this plot are a few
parameters that then describe the relationship that we can
then use to spatially interpolate across the whole surface area of the
whole region. And so we can get a partial sill.
We can get a range. This tells us the distance at which we can
detect spatial autocorrelation.
And then the nugget is essentially the measurement error.
Because what we would think is that as distance goes to zero, which is
the origin here, we should be getting the same exact measure of
disinvestment. But we don't, and so that's how the nugget is a
measure of measurement error.
So based on these parameters, we can then create something like this,
which we now have the measures of disinvestment at these
locations of individuals in our cancer case cohort.
This is not their actual location, by the way. I'm not disclosing PHI.
These are just examples. Okay, so in summary, for
this spatial sense, you say, "Hold on, this is spatiotemporal.
You didn't say a thing about time yet." And that's true.
I want to give the spatial overview first, because to extend it in time, it's quite
simple if you know how it is to do it spatially.
So we audit a random sample of locations.
We conduct our audit based on what we want to actually have measured.
We create a score based on our measurement properties if it allows us to create a
score, if we have suitable internal consistency,
reliability.
We create and fit a semivariogram,
and then we do our spatial interpolation across our region.
We extract the estimates. We link them to
any outcomes that we're interested in based on the address at diagnosis.
Just like Dr. Yanos mentioned, we need that information of address at diagnosis or
address at any outcome. We did this as part of a study
looking at disinvestment in cancer survival as in outcomes,
linking those measures that we just went through to the Women's Circle of Health
Follow-Up Study, which is a cohort of Black women diagnosed with breast cancer in
urban areas in New Jersey
with these eligibility criteria.
I'm going to move a little faster so that Shannon has enough time.
We had a whole bunch of covariates to adjust for
in our models of breast cancer-specific survival
time, which was our outcome, and our main exposure was built environment
disinvestment.
Commonly, what individuals say is that it's not necessarily disinvestment, right?
You look at those neighborhoods I showed you, people say, "It's income.
It's not disinvestment. You got to control for SES." And I agree, you should.
And that's actually what many would say. So we did that.
And so essentially, you can look at any of these models.
Model two and model three
adjust for individual SES or more common measures, education and income.
And what we see is that as disinvestment increases,
survival time, because these are accelerated failure time models, not hazard
ratios.So survival time decreases for those
diagnosed stage two or stage three.
No such associations, or at least they're weaker
associations, for those diagnosed stage one and stage four.
I can talk more about that if anyone's interested in unpacking that.
So there's been other studies done looking at similar associations.
And
the first one arguably was done by Mario Schuetteman.
Graham Colditz is on that paper as well, as you can see lower left.
And they looked at quality of life outcomes and found a peculiar
association. No associations with disinvestment, but an odd
association with sidewalk walkability in that I think it was breast cancer
cases who lived in a more walkable neighborhood
had sharper reductions in quality of life.
So kind of an odd thing. But beyond that, most
of the studies have been done by my team, and I'm hoping others will
try to take up these methods, hence why I'm here.
Because I think there needs to be more replication studies. Okay.
Now the spatiotemporal extension, the temporal extension.
Essentially all it is, is make sure that we're recording the dates that are at some
of these locations. So we sample locations and dates. We do the same audit.
We create the same score if the data says that we can create the same score.
And then we fit not a spatial semivariogram, but a spatiotemporal
semivariogram. So we now have two dimensions, space and time.
And then we create our exposures over space and time.
And here's an example. This is an approximate actual
from one of our spatiotemporal audits in Franklin County, Ohio.
And what we're seeing is that disinvestment does indeed vary
across time, but as you may deduce from looking at these maps, it
varies more across space, essentially.
But there is some variability across time,
including season, which is where it actually varies the most.
Real quick, I'm going to just show you from the same breast cancer case score, we
have epigenetic age acceleration as a measure that Dr.
Alanis mentioned as something biologically we can establish causation and downward
causal pathways. And so
I'm going to real quick give you a sneak peek.
I'm going to be presenting more of this on Monday in the biology and burden of
stress session. But essentially what we found is that
epigenetic age acceleration increases
for each standard deviation increase in disinvestment, that same disinvestment
measure. This was measured across space and time, so a more accurate
measure.
But the confidence interval is a little wide there, so I think the p-value wasn't
quite .05. But there was not much of an association
between neighborhood socioeconomic composition and disinvestment.
I'm sorry, neighborhood composition as measured by
the Yoast index and epigenetic age acceleration.
And these factors were all mutually adjusted for one another.
If you want to know more about this, happy to talk about it, or again, come to the
session on Monday. With that, I'd like to recap and say that we defined the built
environment. We've done that many times. Hopefully, we can all walk away with that.
Classified aspects of the built environment, disinvestment mainly.
We talked about food environment a little bit, as well as walkability.
Identified one data source, Google Street View, which is widely
available across much of the world, as I mentioned already.
Described some of the basic concepts of kriging, including that
semivariogram,
and then interpreted some of our estimates that result.
With that, I'd like to thank you for your attention.
There's a session I'd like to put a plug in for tomorrow by
Trang Vo-Pham, Jamie Hart, and Iona Chang, who will be presenting some interesting
things as well in this space.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, we do. For questions.
Okay. Hi, everyone. Last up before
questions. Thanks for having me. Today, I'll be talking about
incorporating social and structural drivers of health
in community and basic science research.
I have nothing to disclose.
The organization of the presentation is to start with
building off of Dr. Alanis' presentation and give a very brief
overview of what social and structural drivers of health are,
how data linkages of SDOH
with patient data as well as biologic data for multilevel
investigations can help to inform, one, empiric investigations
that can give insights into the biologic basis of disease,
and two,
can provide information based on geospatial analyses that can be
conducted to inform community planning.
So I'm going to start with concepts first and then go into some examples.
So you've seen this before. It's a review of what
social and structural drivers of health are.
They're factors or exposures outside the body, often defined in terms of
the conditions and the places where people live, work, and play.
Unfavorable social and structural determinants of health often result
from discriminatory policies. They're defined in terms of five main
domains: built environment, economic stability, education,
social and community context, and health and healthcare.
They're important to study because we have seen associations with these
factors and cancer outcomes across the continuum from
prevention through survivorship.
Within each of these domains, as Adina mentioned, there are
hundreds to thousands of variables that can represent each of these
domains. Jesse talked a lot about the neighborhood built
environment. I'm going to touch on some of the others.
A lot of the variables that you measure for SDOHs can
come from individual surveys, but they can also come from publicly available
data sets. And that's what I'm going to focus on, those publicly available data
sets at the macro and meso level in this presentation.
So again, as a quick review, where do these macro and meso level
SSDOH factors come from? They come from different data sources.
So we have national registry data, state cancer registry data that
can give us information on cancer incidence rates,
mortality rates,
stage of diagnosis, and survival.
We also can get our SDOH measures from existing data sources
from the US government. So built environment
from Agency for Toxic Substances and Disease Registry, EPA
data. Most of the social education
and access data come from the US Census, for
example.These variable types from these
publicly available data sets are often defined and summarized
in terms of geographic boundaries that are
administratively determined based on the number of residents within an
area. So they're summarized in terms of county or
ZIP code, census tract, or block group.
The smaller the geography, the better, because it's more of a surrogate
for an individual's own exposure.
So in the context of this particular map of Philadelphia, these are
Philadelphia's ZIP codes, and within each of these ZIP codes, there are
much smaller census tract boundaries.
Census tracts have on average about 5,000 residents, compared to 20,000
in a ZIP code. So you prefer to work with that smaller level
geography when you're working with the exposure data.
So you can link these existing data sources
to individual level data from EMRs, electronic
medical records, registry data, cross-sectional surveys, and
cohorts that include information on demographics, psychosocial
factors, or clinical disease information.
And then you can also link that information even further to biobank and
repositories which house those genetic or omics
markers. And the purpose of linking these data sets
together is to create these multilevel data sets where you can begin to
investigate variables at each of these levels
individually and collectively to see how they impact
cancer outcomes, all under a chronic stress hypothesis
that states that we want to understand how factors outside the body
get in under the skin, impact biology, and ultimately
cancer outcomes.
So just like at the biologic level, where
you run assays and you identify molecular markers associated
with disease,
omics markers, proteomics markers, genetic markers,
and then apply high-dimensional computing approaches like machine
learning to identify which markers are associated with treatment
response, for example. You can apply the same methodologies
to the macro level, to the area level data as
well. So it's through these data linkages and then these
common data analysis applying
methods from basic science to social data sets where you
can begin to explore social and environmental
pathways involved in cancer.
So how do you go about doing those data linkages?
So I'm going to start there. We've alluded to this.
So you start doing the data linkages through a process called
geocoding. So for geocoding, what you need there is you have a
patient. Each patient is their own unique ID in the
context of data.
Each patient has their own bio samples that they are linked through
to their own bio sample ID. If you have the
address of a patient, you can take that point
address, run it through statistical software like
ArcGIS to generate a geocode aggregated
up to the neighborhood in which that particular person lives at
a census tract level, for example.
So typically, that would generate a geocode that, again, is based on these
administrative boundaries. So the first two digits often
represent the state, the next three digits the county, and the
following digits represent the census tract or census block group.
So once you have that GEO ID,
you're able to place each participant in the
neighborhood they live in, and then the subsequent neighborhood
exposures that person's exposed to at the
neighborhood level. So you're essentially able to get an exposure profile
for each of the patients and the bio samples.
So you're able to use publicly available data to get exposure
profiles for these types of studies.
So just to give you an example of a study that integrates all of these
levels together. In pancreatic cancer, we've conducted some
studies that show that telomere length is associated with pancreatic cancer
risk. We first identified this in a cohort of Finnish
male smokers.
From there, we've also conducted studies in a multiethnic
cohort that showed that
psychosocial stressors,
anxiety, depression, mental health, is associated with
shorter telomere length under a chronic stress hypothesis.
And we wanted to expand that to see
if, under a chronic stress hypothesis, these macro level
factors, these SSDOH factors, could
also be implicated or associated with
telomere length. And what we found, we
had access to some of these environmental measures.
Even when we adjust for those individual level factors like perceived
stress and depression, that these macro factors,
these SSDOH factors at the macro level, were also
associated with shorter telomere length, suggesting
that this level has its own independent effects
on biology and warrant further investigation.
So since this particular study, there have been other studies
done in other cancer sites like breast cancer.
There's been other markers that we've investigated, like allostatic load is a
project that Adina and Jesse are involved in.
So these are just some examples of how you can integrate this data for biologic
studies.
So
one of the differences
between studies when is the selection of which
SSDOH variables do you want to include in your study.
We've talked about how there's hundreds and even thousands of these
SSDOH variables. So if you want help narrowing down
which variables might be most relevant for your analysis,
one way you can do that is through the application of these
empiric methodologies, like a neighborhood-wide association
study or the utilization of machine learning
analyses.
And I have one example of that here that we worked
on.So our particular research question was:
what neighborhood SSDOH factors are related to aggressive
prostate cancer? Where aggressive prostate cancer was defined
as
stage 3 or greater and grade 7 or greater prostate
cancer. For this study, we linked together the Pennsylvania State
Cancer Registry data that had over 80,000
prostate cancer cases. They were geocoded at the census tract
level and then linked to over 14,000 US
Census variables for analysis. And then from there, we
applied a methodology which I'll get into in a minute, a neighborhood wide
association study, as well as machine learning.
So in this particular study, we conducted NWAS in
Black and White men separately, and that's because
Black men are more likely to be diagnosed with and die of
prostate cancer. So we wanted to see if there were differences in what
SSDOH factors came up within each race ethnic group.
So in this particular data set, there were
900 cases of Black men with aggressive disease versus not,
and in White men,
close to 6,500 cases with aggressive disease versus not.
We applied an NWAS approach, which is similar to genome-wide
association study approach, where you apply
more stringent statistical assessments.
You take regression models, and you might apply Bonferroni corrections,
run principal components analysis.
We also
did a validation study with machine learning, where we simulated
data to see if we got similar results.
So applying these high-dimensional competing approaches, we were
able to identify, within Black men, five variables
from the over 14,000, and within White men, 17 variables
that were most associated with aggressive prostate cancer.
And they were a little bit different among race ethnic groups.
So in Black men, it related to housing, White men, it
related to socioeconomic status and transportation.
And here are some examples of what these variables look like.
They're a little bit more informative than some of the variables that we typically
look at. For example,
one of the variables was percentage of workers taking public transport to work.
So that incorporates components of employment, as well
as transportation in a single variable.
So from here, we wanted to understand
if these variables had any clinical utility in
prostate cancer,
particularly in the context of biomarkers that we know are associated with
PSA in particular. So prostate cancer-specific antigen
is the screening marker used for prostate cancer.
At levels of four nanograms per milliliter, that's typically what they
use to recommend further testing for biopsy.
So in a separate cohort study of men who are at high
risk for prostate cancer, so it included Black men
or White men with a family history in our prostate cancer risk assessment
program. We utilized that data set that has multilevel
data, and we wanted to determine whether the PSA
biomarker, together with some of these SSDOH
variables, could improve the predictive probability of prostate
cancer in this particular sample.
And for this study,
we applied lasso machine learning approaches,
and we looked at each of the SSDOH variables from the NWAS
separately, but we also
looked at them as an exposure score.
So we identified three variables that remain significant.
We used those three variables to generate an exposure score similar to how you
would generate a polygenic risk score from a GWAS
study. From that, we found that
there are poor neighborhood SSDOHs
alone that are associated with prostate cancer in this particular
cohort, and that when you plot your baseline
PSA against your three or five-year predictive probability of
prostate cancer, and you look at men who have a high
exposure score versus a low exposure score, that the
probability of prostate cancer is much higher in men with the high
exposure score, so closer to 30% compared to 8%.
So this would suggest that incorporating this information could
be useful from a clinical standpoint.
So I gave a very brief overview and some examples of how you can
utilize these multilevel data sources, macro-meso
environment with biology, for the purposes of
understanding or exploring the biologic basis of disease, as
well as clinical risk prediction in patients.
But this data can also be useful for geospatial
analyses and community planning efforts.
So that's what I'm going to focus on in the second half of this presentation.
So we want to focus on backer level geography, one,
because these SSDOH variables are essentially place-based variables.
We start it there. And it's important to understand place,
because if we know where the cancer burden is, what the
main contributors are, then we better know how to intervene and
where the research should be targeted.
So my example I have for this is in lung
cancer. So lung cancer in the US and then
also in Pennsylvania and Philadelphia, which is where
Fox Chase Cancer Center is located.
Lung cancer is the second most common cancer.
It's a leading cause of cancer death.
There are two main types of lung cancer, non-small cell and small
cell. Small cell has poorer survival
rates compared to non-small cell.We actually know
a lot about what causes lung cancer, and there are
meso, macro, and micro factors associated.
So, number one is smoking. So we know smoking is the biggest contributor to
lung cancer. There are policies that have been implemented to
help
alleviate the burden of smoking and lung cancer, but there's still work to do.
Radon, air pollution, asbestos are environmental exposures that we
also know are related to lung cancer.
In some places, there are policies in place to address those.
Racial disparities exist in lung cancer.
And then, unfortunately, rates of lung cancer are growing a lot in
non-smokers, and that's why it's really important to take a look at what factors
beyond smoking could be influencing lung cancer rates
in your area. So, one of the goals of
this particular study was to utilize our Pennsylvania State Cancer
Registry data and identify geographic areas at the census tract
level where there were higher rates of lung cancer incidents that were
adjusted for age, race, and gender.
And then from there, we used multiple data sources
to explore how smoking and some of these environmental factors could be
contributing to these clusters, with the goal of identifying
for each cluster what factors are driving
the rates of lung cancer in that cluster, because that's going to get us more to
that precision public health approach in how do you address the burden of cancer in
a very specific area.
So, here are a list of the data sources that we used.
We used the Pennsylvania State Cancer Registry data as well as SEER
data for denominators. Those
variables listed here in gray are our SSDoH variables.
They come from various publicly available data sources
that were available to us at the census tract level.
They relate it to behaviors like smoking, environmental factors,
housing, population density, as well as
employment and socioeconomic variables like education.
We ran a statistical analysis first with SatScan software, which
is freely available for use to
identify where there are areas of higher lung cancer incidence.
Then we applied univariate and multivariable
logistic regression to determine what factors could be contributing to those
clusters. Looked at model fit to then summarize, not
just overall for the state, but for each individual cluster, what are the main
drivers of lung cancer in that area.
So overall, there was over 62,000 lung cancer
cases in Pennsylvania diagnosed at that time.
The majority were white, about 10% were Black.
Here's a map of the state of Pennsylvania.
I'm showing the county-level boundaries, but where you see the circles with the
numbers, that's where we've identified census tracts where there were higher rates
of lung cancer than anticipated.
Next, we ran our multivariate model and we found that
smoking, air pollution, traffic density, and population
density in old homes. So old homes was kind of our surrogate for
asbestos because we didn't have a good measure of asbestos,
remains significantly associated with lung
cancer incidence in these clusters.
So then we went back to the map and we color-coded
what factors were driving each of the clusters.
So smoking played a part in all of the clusters that we identified.
So up here near, the Poconos or Wilkes-Barre, that's
where we would just target our smoking interventions because smoking's the only
thing that came up. But in the other areas, those environmental pieces like
air pollution really played a role.
Because Philadelphia is
where the majority of our patients come from, we did a deeper dive in
Philadelphia area and looked at not just lung cancer incidence, but
mortality. And we've identified those smaller
neighborhoods where the rates of lung cancer mortality were
higher. They have more access to tobacco, where smoking was playing a role,
and then where environmental factors seem to be playing a role.
With that Philadelphia data, that's where we were really able to connect with
our community. So our Office of Community Outreach has
funded pilots with community partners that are located in these
particular areas. One, to focus on smoking cessation,
introducing the community to smoking cessation that we have
available to them. And then also part of the project is
to communicate this information, the findings that we learn from the community,
as well as our data to policymakers.
We're also working with graduate students on a catalyst grant that's
measuring air pollution at certain community partners'
areas so that they can start to get familiar with how you go
about monitoring air pollution,
what these factors mean, and education
surrounding that. And then we've worked together as an
office to begin to incorporate geospatial
analysis in the implementation of our prevention programs
at Fox Chase with the example of smoking cessation
to start with. So we're actually looking at if our patients who are in
this program are actually coming from the high-burden areas, are we actually
reaching them? And if not, where are our community partners that we can
work with to do a better job? And then, of course, we're talking about mobile
screening.
So that's just an example of how SSDoH can inform community
outreach and planning.
There are some limitations to the data I presented to you.
So we've alluded to this before. I'm showing cross-sectional
data at one point in time, but it would be helpful to look at
residential history or changes in exposure over time.
That could be a whole session in and of itself.Also,
I hope what you get out of this presentation is an idea on how you can
capitalize on your existing resources to link together
SSDOH data with resources that you have for hypothesis
generation, and to begin to study biosocial pathways in
cancer and to learn that really this entails
working with multiple collaborators and talking to other people at
your sites. So this is basic scientists talking to population
scientists, and geographers, and implementation scientists, community outreach
teams because that's ultimately what we need to address
cancer disparities at both the population and patient level.
So that's all I have. I want to thank my collaborators, my
lab, and my funders, and I'm here for questions.
So we have
about 20 minutes for questions. We have
some viewers online, so if anyone in the
audience, in the live audience, has questions, please come up to the
mic.
Hi.
My question is for Dr. Lynch. I know you mentioned educating the public about
monitoring for air quality. What interventions
have you found might be advisable aside from monitoring
that we ought to explore, especially for clinicians that are
working with the public?
Mm-hmm. So starting first with the community, our
first step was to meet with community
members that are located in those areas where pollution
may play a part and see if they were interested in working on a potential
pilot. And then from there, we're learning
together on,
one, installing this, and when you install it, when you analyze the
data. Once you analyze the data, how do you communicate these messaging?
So we're using it as a way to get community feedback so we can do
a better job of explaining to them, and then ultimately
policymakers, what they think is needed or what
it means. So we're starting small
there.
And then what was your second question?
It wasn't just community you were interested in.
Yeah. I guess, how are you building that connection with the community
so that they let you into their home to put up that device or whatever it is that
you're using to measure?
Yeah. So
through our Office of Community Outreach, we have existing partners,
and we know where they're located.
So we start with those, and then we work with them and their
networks on who they think may be interested.
We also are working on introducing research more
to the community in our catchment.
So we're putting together a cohort study where we
talk to people about what a cohort study is, and we let them join.
We analyze their survey data in real time and give it back to them
to try to connect them to care. So it's a way for us to build
trust in that way. So we're trying to get new partners in that
way, and then we're also trying to work with our existing partners and their
networks to expand.
That's wonderful. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hi.
Wonderful. I learned a lot, which is actually the goal,
so thank you for that. I was interested--
I got overwhelmed with so many things.
There are so many parameters, there are so many
considerations. So
is your field organizing a way to bring a
consensus, so
all of us are trying to gather data that can help everybody
else?
Or is this too nascent? And I
apologize for being naive.
Yeah. So that's a really good question because
a lot of us, and you even saw in the context of our presentation,
are working on different variables that represent different
domains of social determinants of health.
And I'd say right now, everyone's kind of doing
something a little bit individually, but there is efforts
to
coalesce this at the national level.
So for example, there are mapping sites.
There's a mapping site called Cancer in Focus.
I was just at a catchment area meeting where we're trying to work
with all the cancer centers to look within each
catchment and share environmental data that all of us have
collected in a single spot. So I can
update my catchment with an exposure variable that somebody
at Kentucky put together. So we are starting to
do that. I think we can do a better job of making sure
that as these are created, they're housed somewhere.
NCI also started trying to do these types of initiatives,
but that slowed down more recently.
I'll just add, I think a lot of
population scientists,
geospatial epidemiologists, and not just in the cancer
space, but many other areas, they focus on
sort of their favorite measures, right?
I'd say, Jesse, one of your favorite measures is probably physical
disorder and disinvestment. That's not the only one you study, but I think
people are focused on different things, and there really are
thousands of these measures.
But again, in sort of what I was explaining, we have to think about the
timing of the exposure and whether we can
have all of those measures available at every time point that
could be of interest for every population.
So I do think it would be a great idea to think of what
are the basicVariables that
would be available at
certain times. But I think the time piece is the one
aspect that I think would be the most complicated.
Because
it really depends on what your reference point is
and whether that reference point is relevant to the outcome in the
population you're studying. So I don't know.
Maybe there could be a database of all the measures.
Because in these times of all of the omics and the entire
machine learning and all of the data compiling
efforts that are going on in biology-
Yeah
... we see the same problem.
We're talking about the same problem.
One of the things that I thought to propose
here is hooking up with ACR,
because
talking with them and working with them could help with initiatives, and also
it can drive you all the way to the policy-making as well.
Yeah. I think that's a really good idea, and we have to start
somewhere, right? Thank you for that question.
Hi, I'm Jeannie Mandelblatt, and I really enjoyed the
panel discussion. You provided a wonderful overview
of measures. I wanted to get a little bit of your thoughts on the
basic cancer research portion.
I think I saw one example, and I'm wondering one of the
issues, you guys are population scientists,
you're not probably going to become basic scientists, but how do you
collaborate with basic scientists about using
tools or things they're discovering to go
backwards or forwards to try to identify the
pathways? Because you might come up with a
pharmaceutical intervention or another type of pathway.
You discussed you need to not just put something in as
a confounder, but you're looking at mediators.
You're trying to find pathways. So I wonder what your experience and your
advice would be to others on that.
Thank you, Dr. Mandelblatt, for that.
I think the answer perhaps is in your
comment of collaborating. I remember when
I first was working on the project that had some of that epigenetic data
that supported the collection of the epigenetic data, I was talking to a mentor.
This is for my K, and that project's from a K07,
actually. And I was thinking of doing something very social with nothing
biologic. And my mentor said, "You could do that, but I think it's going to be a
lot stronger and you'll understand and build a lot more knowledge
if you try to incorporate some of the biologic pathways." And so from there,
it was working with individuals who know more about that stuff, Dr.
Giannos was one of them,
and others, and that's what led to that.
So I think it's having the conversations.
So talking to others about where this work could interface
with the cutting edge things that are going on in the
molecular biology space
is a way to go with that. Yeah.
Do you also have an answer?
Yeah. Go ahead.
So I'll say we are starting to think about that quite a bit.
I didn't present any of our current work, but we're
looking at single cell gene expression in the breast tumor
microenvironment and linking that with structural and
social measures that we discussed.
I'm also interested in stress and allostatic
load, and how can we measure allostatic load better?
What are the molecular mechanisms, as you said,
collaborating with pathologists and systems biologists,
geneticists. It really is an interdisciplinary
approach, and I think we're starting it, but there are so many
different directions we can go, from epigenetics to
all the other omics, exposomics.
Mm-hmm.
I think there are endless possibilities.
Yeah, and just to piggyback on that, too, so at Fox
Chase, we've been working on tumor
microenvironmental markers, so identifying pancreas and linking that with the
macro environment to see how they relate to one another.
So I think the conversations are happening.
The difference is, I don't think there's a great
mechanism to get these conversations started.
So they started at Fox Chase because we have
a pancreatic cancer steering committee where we're able to explore
ideas.
Prior to coming to Fox Chase, I did work at NCI for a bit on the
breast cancer and the environment research centers, and one of the challenges
working with basic scientists, epidemiologists, or even community advocates, is
getting everyone to speak the same language.
So it's really hard to start the conversation
if you feel like you're from two different worlds.
So coming up with mechanisms or places where we can have these
conversations that start with basic, like what is common
language we can share to generate these ideas is needed.
And then I also think there has to be investment from funders for
interest in these areas. Because I don't know about you, but when I've
applied for funding that
links these concepts together, it gets mixed reviews.
It's not considered a huge priority, which
is a challenge because cancer is
complex, and we need to look at it from these different angles, but the funders
don't see it that way. They're still looking at the very basic or
the very population, and integrating the two is a challenge.
So if there's a way that we can come up with specific working
groups or funding announcements that support that,
that would be great.
Hello. Thank you guys so much for the wonderful talks.
And kind of piggybacking on a lot of the things that you have said,
especially in terms of the policymaking and actually advocating
for work like this to be implemented on
a wider scale for a lot of the upstream things we're interested in.
So I'm just curious, in your experience or either from what you've heard from
colleagues, and I know there's a lot of randomized control trials that try to
address some structural and social determinants of health that have been effective,
but I guess, how can you work with policymakers or ensure you're
getting the proper outlets to advocate for your work to be implemented
into standard of care? And what has your experience been with that?
And then just some insight for a young investigator.
Who wants to answer that? Hmm.
I don't think any of us have
the best answer to that, but I think that these are things that
as these conversations are happening, we really should be thinking
about.
One thing is even connecting with policymakers
so they fully understand what we're doing, what we're
finding, and
how that can impact their constituents, and whether
they can support
more funding in these areas.
Implementing in clinical spaces, I'm not
really sure. I know a lot of
facilities are now collecting social determinants of health data,
but my question is,
even unmet needs and some of these measures that are collected, what are we
doing with it? Yeah. Right? So we're
collecting the data now. That's a start, but how are we
improving outcomes based on
SSDoH? So I think we're moving towards that.
But yeah, I don't know if you guys have. Yeah.
I'm looking at Electra Paskett right here, and I'd be remiss to say that with
patient navigation programs, I think that's one way that there's an interface
where if barriers identified, including housing
instability, including other things that are well in the
realm of social determinants of health, patient navigators are
trained and equipped to connect patients with those
resources to
keep them from being a barrier to treatment to--
And maybe more can be mentioned by the expert.
Yeah. Electra's going to give us an example.
Yeah. So
back to one of the original frameworks that Adana showed, which came from
the Centers for Population Health and Health Disparities.
One of the centers there
that was led by D**k Warnecke looked at the problem of
higher mortality rates from breast cancer in women in
Chicago, especially on the South Side of Chicago.
And they actually plotted where these
women lived,
and then they looked at the healthcare facilities and the mammography
facilities where these women would go to get their mammograms.
And they formed the Chicago Breast
Cancer Task Force. Excuse me. And what
they looked at at those facilities where these
women went, these women had higher mortality rates, higher stage of late
stage disease. They found that at these
facilities, the quality of the mammograms were
subpar.
The techs that were reading the mammograms were not
certified to read mammograms.
And when a woman had a positive mammogram, there were no
navigators. There were no systems in place to get
the women back in for timely follow-up.
And, of course, to go to care, they had to travel
outside of their areas to the cancer center.
So they worked
with advocates at the ground level and then
policymakers, including the governor and the state
legislature. And they enacted several laws,
and one of them was a quality law.
So
what gets health systems to do something?
What do you have to hit? What pain point?
Money.
Money. Money.
Money. So if you wanted to get reimbursement for your
mammograms, your facility had to be
performing quality mammograms. So they would come and
inspect them with the phantom and things like that.
And then you also had to ensure follow-up, and so they started
a patient navigation program in Chicago.
And,
oh, I'm sure a couple of other things I can't
recall off the top of my head, but again, it started with looking at where
the women lived. All right? Mapping.
Mm-hmm.
So we have geography there, and then where they got care, and then going
in and seeing the quality of the care, which is at the clinic
level. And they brought it up to the policy to do something that trickled
down, and they saw a reduction in the death rate in
Black women in Chicago.
That's a really good example.
That's a really good example. Yeah. You know what I would add to that?
And
I don't know if this ever happens, but reimbursement for patient
navigators. Is this happening yet,
right? We know that patient navigation works, not just in cancer,
but policy, right?
Yeah. I don't want this to be addressed.
But I think that that's a really good point.
Okay. So patient navigations, some of you in the room might have been part of the
original Patient Navigation Research program, which NCI and the American Cancer
Society funded to prove the efficacy of patient navigation.
And it works. And it was set to work to get people who had
positive
mammograms, colon screening, breast, and prostate
screening in for appropriate care, timely care, and
it worked, okay? Everything was positive.And so,
then navigation kind of caught on.
We have accrediting bodies and institutions
started getting
navigators. American Cancer Society started the National Navigation Roundtable,
and we lobbied,
along with the Biden administration, to get
patient navigation a covered service.
So yes, we did get that, but
the problem is we do not want people to get a
copay for having a navigator.
Mm.
And the way it's set up right now is that patients could get a copay.
The other thing is the billing,
it's pin codes. They use pin codes and things like that.
It's a little complex for institutions to figure
out. Institutions are starting to figure it out.
They're also figuring out how not to bill the patient for the copay,
and there are some other questions like, do you have to be supervised by
a physician to do the billing and all this stuff?
So it is getting figured out.
Got it.
But it is still not universally used
because the law that was made or the policy that was
passed was not user-friendly.
Thank you. So yes, to answer your question,
the evidence that we're generating in the cancer space
is
impactful even at the policy level, but we need more of
that. Right? So thank you, Electra.
Thank you, Electra. This was a great session, and actually I was just going to
follow up that next year we need to join forces and have our implementation
science session and our built environment session come together and start to
think about interventions and implementation.
Sure.
Really great job. I love the overview and I love the individual scientific
examples, and it's always great to hear from the work of all three of you, so
really great job.
My first question actually is for Jesse. So Dr.
Placek,
we talk a lot, I think NCI has put a lot of focus on persistent poverty
areas, and I wanted to just get your sense of what is this
overlap or distinction between persistent poverty and
neighborhood
divestment. Do you see them as overlapping concepts?
Really distinct concepts? And how should we go about sort of intervening on those
differently?
Yeah, so
as you know,
being at ASPO, there was a session on the persistent poverty projects that
Shoba, I forget Shoba's last name, but--
Srinivasan, thank you. Program officer at NCI,
really led, and I think it was four or five projects that are focused on persistent
poverty areas. And I think a lot of them have
RCT components essentially to
see if there's ways that that causal chain can be broken from residing in
a persistently impoverished area and health behaviors and
outcomes that related to cancer or explicitly cancer.
I would say that the causal relationship between
disinvestment and poverty is probably complicated
and cyclical, such that individuals impoverished are more likely to be
living in disinvested areas through
structural discriminatory processes and
pathways, some of the same that led them to persistent poverty in the first
place. What I would say, and I talked to Shoba at the meeting,
was poverty is something probably if most of us are interested in
social determinants, we should be studying because it's probably the thing that's
driving the most of the variation we see.
It's probably poverty.
But what's the political traction for studying poverty as an
intervention, right? And I said before your
call for projects, like I never would've thought of studying poverty.
So, the reason why I'm studying disinvestment is personally, I feel like it's a
lever that we can pull more so, and there is RCT evidence that it may be
associated with stress pathways, and we think that there's more evidence that
stress is associated with various cancer outcomes.
And so that's why I'm focusing on that, but I think poverty would be a great thing
to study, but what's the traction for that?
It wasn't a trick question. Can go either way.
So my follow-up to that, though, is speaking of connecting to policy
makers and thinking about the health policy relevance,
when we think about, we talk about divestment, but have you
seen across even just those tracts in New Jersey or those areas in
New Jersey, an upward trend of investment?
And can we look at it in kind of that positive way to
get policy makers-
Yeah
... and community advocates on board for
exemplars.
Right. Yeah, I have not looked at that.
I've started to dig into it a little bit because we have such rich data spatially
and temporally, and so essentially looking to see if there's areas that are
really having different trajectories of investment or disinvestment and
to see if that's associated. But analytically, I have not yet, but I think
that's a fantastic idea.
Okay.
So Jesse and I, we've actually talked about this a lot, thinking
about gentrification. So I think that if you think about
places that have been further invested, it's actually
worse for some communities, especially those that
disproportionately shoulder a burden. So I think it's tricky.
It's different, right? There's gentrification, but there's also community
investment that we've seen where we have seen positive-
So, yeah. I think one of the examples that Shannon
showed in Philly, the green space, Bernadette Hole was involved in that,
and I think that we've seen evidence that even adding
parks and safe places for people to
be physically active has a positive impact on many
health outcomes. But I think when you think about
neighborhood investment and how that looks
in certain places, especially in inner cities that were
gentrified, like the people that live there
You know, for generations don't benefit.
So I think it-
And how it--
Yeah.
But I don't know how to do that. No, of course.
I know, but I think that to your point and what Jesse is saying, it's hard
to measure that, and the measurement
is likely to be different depending on
what's been changed
and why it's been changed.
Oh, yes. So
we'll take one more question, but then the session is
over. We are the last in the room, so we'll stay up here if folks want to come up
to us individually.
Yeah. This is a super
well-organized session. I believe everybody, including me,
really benefits from this session.
I have two questions. The first one is to Dr.
Jesse Plasek. So when you use
Google Street View,
I think you mentioned that you check different seasons, you
see their season variation. I think the most figures you show is on
a sunny day. I'm very curious, like when it's maybe
a rainy day, like a snowy day or maybe cloudy day.
Basically, with more repeated
measurements on the same neighborhood,
how you see
such important thing like impact the
visibility can impact your assessment.
A follow-up for that is does
Google Street View evenly
scan every neighborhood? My guess may be
some neighborhoods may be scanned more than the other neighborhoods,
which itself can also lead to a measurement
issue for assessment. My second question is to Dr.
Shannon Lynch. I think one slide you mentioned
transportation is a factor for the white man,
I think for the
prostate cancer outcomes. I think that's very interesting.
What's the transportation there meaning, like transportation to
a health center or something? I think one thing that
could be related, maybe there is delayed for the
white man, like for the PSA screening due to transportation.
Which is something we can work on,
we could do transportation reimbursement or free parking or something can
improve on that. So that's my two questions. Mm-hmm.
So I'll be quick with my response. You mentioned the seasonality.
I think I kind of forgot what you were asking about that, so you can come ask me
afterwards. But with the data availability, the data
is indeed spatiotemporally structured in terms of
availability. So there are more images across
time in urban areas, and in rural areas, you may only have
one or two images. Google sent the car out in 2007 for the first time.
That may be the only image in some rural areas is 2007.
So you may not have recent images in some of these more rural areas.
The only kind of good thing about that is that physical disorder
is traditionally conceptualized as an urban construct.
So, thinking about graffiti on some area in a rural
area, it may lose some of its significance, and it may actually be quite rare.
And so,
the problem may work itself out a little bit.
But
yeah, we could talk more about the first part if you want afterwards.
Yeah.
Yes. Thank you. Oh, you're going to address this question quickly.
Okay.
So for the question about the finding in transportation
in prostate cancer in men. So
we delved into that a little bit more, and it's neighborhoods where
there's a higher percentage of workers, but not really great public transport.
That was the association we saw. So that would suggest that
access to care is an issue. So some of the ways to
address that, beyond allowing people who actually get
to the cancer center to have transportation, it's
we're looking into expanding our mobile unit.
We have a breast cancer mobile unit, so we're able to
now take bloods on that unit, and we're looking to expand that to prostate
cancer. So going into those areas where transportation may
be an issue, but the burden of prostate cancer is high, is something that we're
looking into based on those findings.
Okay. Thanks everyone for staying for this full session.
We hope you learned a lot.